it is graduation weekend for college
students here in nevada today unlv
hosting an in-person commencement
ceremony for 2021 grads
this is of course file video students
are graduating outdoors this year at sam
boyd
stadium it is today tomorrow and
saturday
oldest graduate this year 76 years young
the youngest is 19 years old wow on
friday night there is a ceremony
dedicated to the class of 2020 grads
who have been waiting a long time a
whole year to walk across that stage
and receive their diploma so
congratulations to all the graduates
and we want to celebrate with you here
at channel 8 so to honor your graduating
student
any level upload a photo of them along
with their name to
we will feature them on air here in the
next couple of
weeks but we are so excited to do that
we've got a lot of local grads yeah
nate's son just graduated we've got ron
paul here with his sister graduating so
it's exciting and we should also shout
out csn graduation is coming up this
weekend unlv the undergrads are tomorrow
as well so
a lot of graduations kind of it's that
season alex yeah